[Music]
game theory can be applied to scientific
understanding in a lot of different ways
one of the interesting things about
contemporary science is that it's done
by these large groups of people who are
interacting with one another
so science isn't just a lone scientist
in his lab removed from everyone else
but rather it's teams working together
sometimes in competition with other
teams who are trying to beat them out to
make a big discovery
so it's become much more like a kind of
economic interaction these scientists
are striving for credit from their peers
for grants from federal agencies and so
a lot of the decisions that they make
are strategic in nature they're trying
to decide what things will get funded
what strategies are most likely to lead
to a scientific advance how can they do
things so as to get a leg up on their
competition and also get the acclaim of
their peers game theory helps us to
understand how the incentives that
scientists face in trying to get credit
in trying to get grants in trying to get
acclaim might affect the decisions that
they make and sometimes there are cases
where scientists striving to get a claim
can actually make science worse because
a scientist might commit fraud if he
thinks he can get away with it where a
scientist might rush a result out the
door even though she's not completely
sure that it's correct in order to beat
the competition so those of us who use
game theory in order to try and
understand science apply it in order to
understand how those incentives that
scientists face might eventually impact
their ability to produce truths and
useful information that we as a society
can go on or how those incentives might
encourage them to do things that are
harmful to the progress of science by
either publishing things that are wrong
or fraudulent or even withholding
information that would be valuable this
is one of the big problems that a lot of
people have identified with the way that
scientists scientific incentives work
right now scientists get credit for
publication and they're encouraged to
publish exciting new findings that
demonstrate some new phenomena that
we've never seen before but when a
scientist fails to find something that's
informative to the fact that I was
unable to reproduce a result
another scientist shows that maybe that
was an error but the way that the system
is set up right now I wouldn't get
credit for publishing what's called a
null result a finding where I didn't
discover something that somebody else
had claimed to discover so as a result
when we look at the scientific results
that show up in the journals that have
been published it turns out that that's
skewed towards positive findings and
against null results a lot of different
people have suggested that we need to
change the way that scientists are
incentivized by rewarding scientists
more for both publishing no results and
for trying to replicate the results of
others in particular in fields like
psychology and medicine places where
there's a lot of findings and there are
lots of things to look at people really
think that we might want to change the
incentives a little bit in order to
encourage more duplication of effort in
order to make sure that a kind of
exciting but probably wrong result
doesn't end up going unchallenged in the
literature
traditionally until very recently
scientists were mostly looking for the
acclaim of their peers you succeeded in
science when you got the acclaim of you
know another scientist in your field or
maybe some scientists outside your field
but now as the area of science
journalism is increasing the public is
starting to get interested in science
and so scientists are starting to be
rewarded for doing things that the
public is interested in this has a good
side and a bad side the good side is it
means that scientists are driven to do
research that has public impact that
people are gonna find useful and
interesting and that helps to encourage
scientists not just to pursue some
esoteric question that maybe is
completely irrelevant to people's
everyday life the bad side is that now
scientists are encouraged to do things
that will make a big splash get an
article in the New York Times or make
them go viral on the Internet but not
necessarily things that are good science
and so one of the things that people are
concerned with is that this new
incentive being popular with the public
can make scientists shift towards
research that's likely to be exciting
but not necessarily true because the
public doesn't discover when 10
later we decide that the research was
wrong
they just remembered the research that
they read about in the New York Times
ten years before and so the danger is
that lots of misinformation can get
spread when scientists are warded for
making a big splash one of the things
that we've really discovered through
this use of game theory in studying
science is that it's really very
complicated that scientists striving to
get credit from their peers might
initially seem counterproductive you
think well scientists should care about
truth and nothing more but instead
what's actually going on is that
sometimes the desire for credit can
actually do things that are really good
for science scientists are encouraged to
publish their results quickly rather
than sort of keeping them secret until
they're absolutely positively sure and
that can actually be beneficial because
then other scientists can build on it
can use it in their discoveries all of
that's the good side there's also a bad
side which is that striving for credit
can sometimes encourage scientists to
skew towards one project or another and
not distribute their labor as a
community of scientists over a bunch of
different projects one thing that's
really important in science is that
scientists work on different projects
because we don't know which project is
going to end up working out there are
many different ways to say detect
gravitational waves or many different
ways to try and discover a subatomic
particle and what we want is scientists
to distribute themselves so that we have
groups working on each different project
the desire for credit can sometimes
encourage them to be too homogeneous to
adopt to all jump on board with what
looks like the best project and not
distribute themselves in a good or
useful way across all the different
projects nobody really has a good idea
yet of how to balance these because
there's a good side and a bad side
we don't want scientists to be
completely divorced from the world but
on the other hand the danger is if we
put too much emphasis on public reward
and the and the acclaim of the public
then we worried that we have scientists
just generating false but exciting
results over and over and over again in
an attempt to get popular acclaim
[Music]